ايام قليله تفصل البريطانيين عن تتويج
ملكهم الجديد والاجواء الاحتفاليه بدات
ترسم شكل المكان ولكن وراء التحضيرات
الجاريه اجراءات امنيه مشدده تملا كل ركن
من طول الخط الذي سيسلكه موكب الملك
الجديد في السادس من مايو اغلاق شوارع
ونصب حواجز وقطع طرق امام الماره من اهم
الاجراءات الامنيه هذا الظاهر منها للعيان
د كما ترين من خلفك هناك حواجز وضعت بينما
نتحدث الان قبل اقتراب موعد الحدث نفسه
حيث بدات الشرطه بمعاينه المناطق داخل
وحول قصر باكينغهام ودير كما ستنزل الشرطه
الى المصارف للتاكد من عدم وجود اي شيء
تحت الارض كما سيفتشون اعمده الاناره
والاشجار سيكون بحثا مكثفا للغايه
مخاوف عناصر الامن متعدده على راسها
التهديدات الارهابيه التي عاده ما يتم
التعامل معها من قبل عناصر الاستخبارات
الداخليه التي ستنتشر بزين مدني بين حشود
الناس المصطفى اما الخطر الاخر القائم
فيتمثل في الافعال التخريبيه التي قد تصدر
عن مناهضين للعائله الملكيه كرمي البيض او
ما شابهه وعاده ما يحرص هؤلاء على الظهور
خلال مناسبات ملكيه كهذه للاستفاده من
التغطيه الاعلاميه الضخمه
سيكون لديك ضباط شرطه بملابس مدنيه
يتجولون ولديهم معلومات استخباراتيه مسبقه
هناك افراد مثلا لديهم تاريخ في كونهم
معادين للملكيه وقد يقومون بافعال مثل
القاء البيض او التخريب والضباط سيعرفون
من هم
على طول هذا المسار سيسير الملك تشارلز
الثالث وزوجته الملكه كاملا من دير وست
منستر وحتى قصر بوكيهم ليطل من الشرفه
الملكيه على عامه الناس لاول مره كملك على
العرش البريطاني كما نرى بدات الاجراءات
الامنيه في هذه المنطقه منذ اسابيع طبعا
حواجز وخطط لضبط حركه مئات الالاف من
الناس الذين من المتوقع ان يصطفوا على طول
هذا الشارع المفتوح امام المتفرجين اما
بالنسبه للمدعوين فقد نصبت لهم هذه
المدرجات بالقرب من القصر وذلك من اجل
مشاهده فعاليات التتويش من لندن عروب عبد
الحق العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات